all right guys apple event is finally
coming tomorrow and we literally just
got some drastic changes to the leaks
for this event which are both exciting
and disappointing with the addition of
some pretty bad last minute news so in
this video i'm gonna give you guys my
final predictions for features and
changes to each product we're expecting
and then you guys can come back tomorrow
to see if i was right or wrong which is
gonna make this a whole lot more
interesting now before i get into the
really bad news for tomorrow's event i
want to share some absolutely amazing
news with you guys and that's the
confirmation that the entire iphone 13
lineup will come with 128 gigabytes of
storage including the lower end models
which used to come with only 64. this is
a huge deal for all those people who
always buy the base model and struggle
with low amounts of storage and it kind
of points to apple making some huge
camera changes which i'll talk about in
just a minute and with that said it's
time to get into the bad news but first
i want to ask you guys to hit that
subscribe button below because only
around 23 of you are actually subscribed
so go ahead and do that because we're
gonna be going more in depth than ever
before with the new apple products this
fall especially the m1x macbook pros so
definitely subscribe and check out our
merch like our m1x chip shirt design or
our apple product icon shirt down in the
merch shelf right below this video with
that said the bad news is that mark
german came out and confirmed that there
will be two events with the ipad updates
happening at the second event and not
tomorrow now this actually kind of makes
sense for the ipad mini 6 redesign but i
honestly expected the regular ipad 9 to
get released at this event because the
regular ipad always gets released in
either march or september so i still
think there's a chance that it could be
coming tomorrow but i'm not sure and as
far as the rumored air pods 3 ming choco
came out again and confirmed that they
will be coming at tomorrow's event and i
totally agree because i personally think
that both the iphone 13 lineup and the
airpods 3 will be coming with bluetooth
5.2 and other improvements to enable
some new cool features so i think that
they're going to be revealed tomorrow
but the actual shipment date might be
delayed quo also believes that there are
two scenarios for the pricing with the
first scenario being that the airpods 3
are priced higher than the current
airpods while the airpods 2 will remain
the same price and the second scenario
is that the airpods 3 will take over the
current
price and the airpods 2 will be
discounted and that's the exact scenario
that i think is going to happen as far
as the apple watch series 7 both ming
chu ko and gurman agree that it will in
fact be revealed at tomorrow's event now
initially german thought that they would
be in low supply because of production
issues but quo recently said that the
issues have been resolved so the supply
could actually be just fine we also got
some new leaks of the iphone 13 cases
which all seem to have a huge physical
ridge around the camera bump which
points to not only thicker camera lenses
but i think the entire protruding carved
glass bump will be quite a lot thicker
than before and the whole reason for
that is because the camera sensors will
likely be bigger than before which
requires the camera glass to be larger
pitaka actually sent some of their cases
over to our office like the air which is
insanely thin and light and as you can
see the camera bump on the 13 pro max is
quite a bit larger than my current 12
pro max i also noticed that the case is
a little bit loose which points to the
next iphone being quite a bit more thick
which means that it's going to be
getting a bigger battery matching up to
previous leaks but now with all those
new leaks out of the way let's get into
my full list of predictions for the
iphone 13 lineup before i get into the
other products we're expecting the same
four models as last year with exactly
the same 5.4 6.1 and 6.7 inch displays
they're also gonna come with a smaller
notch that is coming due to apple
relocating the earpiece speaker and
upgrading to the new second generation
face id sensors that work with masks and
foggy glasses which is amazing however
the pro models will be coming with extra
features like 120 hertz refresh rate and
an always on display which will run at 1
hertz when in standby mode unless you
get a notification now turning on low
power mode on the pro models will
throttle the display down to 60 hertz so
it's actually going to be much more
useful than before for improving battery
life but other than that the display
should be staying more or less the same
they're all of course going to be coming
with the new a15 bionic chip which will
be similar to the a14 but there's a
chance it'll be built on the rv9
technology wi-fi 6e will come to the
entire lineup most likely with bluetooth
5.2 on all models as well and the new
qualcomm x60 modem which will improve
data speeds and reliability across the
board there's a chance that the iphone
13 lineup will support 25 watt fast
charging but i'm honestly not sure if
it's actually going to be coming on top
of that we should expect stronger
magnets for mac safe across the board as
well as larger wireless charging coils
to handle heat better we should
definitely expect the lightning port to
stick around on all of the models and
leaks are pointing to no under display
touch id coming to any of the iphone 13s
now as far as the cameras the lower end
iphone 13 models will have a diagonal
camera bump
all cameras will be getting larger
sensors which will increase light input
by 15 percent and this will require the
camera lens glass to be larger or
thicker which is why we're expecting the
bigger camera bumps the ultrawide
cameras on all iphone 13 models will be
getting a huge upgrade with a larger
aperture which will let in 40 more light
which is gonna reduce noise and improve
quality and because of this the lens is
going to support auto focus the pro
models will continue to get an extra
telephoto camera and this time around
the smaller model could be switching to
the same 2.5 x optical zoom lens and
they're both going to be looking better
because of the larger sensor the image
stabilization system should improve this
year across the board with the smaller
pro model likely to adopt the sensor
shift stabilization feature there are
also going to be some massive night mode
improvements across the board including
a new astrophotography mode and much
better scene recognition and color
science but the biggest camera feature
is going to be exclusive to the pro
models because it's going to be using
the second generation lidar scanner this
feature is going to be the new portrait
video recording mode called cinematic
video which will give a nice blurry
background to your video clips and it's
going to use the new prores video format
to do it however i expect the selfie
camera on every iphone 13 model to
support this new feature moving on mark
grumman believes that we'll be getting
new portrait filters that can be applied
only to the subject instead of the
entire image and as far as the color
options the regular iphone 13 models
could be seeing a new pink color while
the pro models could be getting new
matte black and bronze colors now i
personally believe that all four models
will be available to order at the same
time on friday which shipments arriving
on the 24th and i think the prices are
going to be staying identical to last
year's pricing even despite the base
storage going up to 128 gigs on the base
models now moving on to the apple watch
series 7 it's pretty clear that it's
going to be getting a new squarish
design that looks basically the same as
the renders that john prosser revealed
months ago however i expect the glass to
be almost completely flat due to the new
ceramic shield display that is going to
be a bit larger 41 and 45 millimeters
thanks to thinner display bezels i also
think that the display is gonna look a
bit better almost like the display is on
top of the glass due to the new
lamination technique that mark german
leaked recently the speaker should also
be seeing a major upgrade with the new
grille layout hinting at much better
speaker quality and i personally think
that all of the current watch bands will
continue to support the new apple watch
design but many of the bands out there
might not look perfectly flush so people
are going to be wanting to upgrade to
the newer bands it's also likely that
the series 7 will come with a bunch of
new apple watch faces like mark german
mentioned but i don't think that there's
going to be any changes to the sensors
on the bottom of the watch as far as the
other changes we can expect things like
wi-fi 6 or 6e support bluetooth 5.2
support a new faster s7 chip upgraded
ultra wide band technology and a larger
battery than before all of these changes
are going to help the series 7 get a
pretty large battery life improvement
but we shouldn't expect any new major
health features or changes and probably
no addition of touch id or anything like
that there's also a chance that we could
be seeing a new color option like the
green that john prosser showed off but i
don't expect any major changes to the
more expensive finishes but other than
that we could potentially see some
upgrades like double the ram from one
gig to two and maybe a storage upgrade
and as far as the other models that are
gonna continue to be sold i still expect
apple to sell both the series 3 and the
se in the lineup while the new series 7
will be sold for the same 399 dollars as
before now moving on to the airpods 3 i
expect them to be kind of a hybrid model
between the regular earpods and the
airpods pro they'll adopt the new design
with a shorter stem as well as the pinch
to click buttons that the airpods pro
currently have however they will not use
silicon ear tips so they're going to
have a more free design which means that
they are not going to have active noise
cancellation i expect the speakers to be
upgraded for better sound quality and
bass but i don't think they'll sound as
good as the airpods pro the main point
of this upgrade is going to be to make
them look a bit more modern as well as
adding wireless charging to the case as
a standard feature alongside the upgrade
to the better pinch controls along with
that the battery life will improve by 20
for the case itself and a pretty nice
improvement for the earbuds themselves
but i also have a feeling that both the
airpods 3 and the iphone 13 lineup will
include bluetooth 5.2 to enable a really
cool new feature but i'm not exactly
sure what that's going to be just yet i
expect the earpods 3 to be priced at 199
just 50 less than the airpods pro and 50
dollars more than the beast studio buds
and i think there's a chance that the
shipment could be delayed by a week or
two but i'm not really sure and finally
let's finish off with the ipad 9 which
might get revealed at tomorrow's event
with this ipad i'm not expecting any
major changes except for a thinner body
due to apple finally laminating the
display like they do for the other ipads
this should get rid of the gap between
the glass and the display as well as
improving colors alongside dci p3 wide
color gamut support and giving it deeper
blacks but other than that i actually
think that the display could stick with
the same 10.2 inch size but with apple
upgrading the chip to the a13 bionic and
that's basically it i'm also pretty sure
that the price will remain at the same
329 dollars as before and there you guys
go that's basically all that we should
expect for this event with other
products like the ipad mini 6 and the
m1x macbook pros coming probably at next
month's event hopefully you enjoy this
video and if you're excited for
tomorrow's apple event go ahead and
click the subscribe button above and
definitely check out our merch down
below thanks for watching and we'll see
you in tomorrow's video
[Music]